I think when the most exciting phenomena
has been been elucidated and really
brought to the forefront by dr. Xavier
Castellanos a child and adolescent
psychiatrist who years before a decade
ago was telling us that the real action
in the brain is while the brains at rest
not while the brain is doing stuff and
so you have to understand that when we
were trying to find we're looking for
the biomarker we're looking for the
equivalent of a blood test if you come
into a doctor's office and you're
coughing and you have a chest cold and
the cold makes you feel terrible we can
do a blood test and tell you whether or
not it's a virus or if it's bacterial if
it's bacterial we give you antibiotics
if the virus we just wait for the virus
to die you will live longer than the
virus so we give you stuff to make you
feel better with it's Tylenol or it's
aspirin it's plenty of fluids but
there's no medicine to make it go away
we don't have that in psychiatry that's
the Holy Grail
what's the biomarker and so very when
the MRI came in or the cat scan first
but the MRI became the new way to look
at the brain these neuro imaging tools
and so first came the structural MRI to
look at how does the brain how is it
built and is it built differently in
people who have a certain psychiatric
illness versus normal versus someone
with a different kind of psychiatric
illness and while that gave us some
hints as group differences it wasn't as
specific as the functional MRI which can
actually take a look at your brain and
see how it works now originally we would
put kids or adults into this machine and
have them do a task so that if you were
at a social anxiety disorder and so
mediate seeing faces that you knew
versus faces that you didn't know should
activate different parts of your brain
and it was very hard to find a
difference when you when you showed
these these tasks or made these tasks
and so what happened was Castellanos
said this is kind of like the post
office when the post office is closed
there's a lot of action going on there
that's when people are talking to each
other they're moving bags of mail
they're organizing themselves when the
window comes up to sell you the stamps
or to accept your mail there's really a
lot less action going on so he basically
said the brain is talking to itself all
the time when it's resting when it's
sleeping and we must have you can tell
the difference between the way the brain
speaks to itself when you have ADHD or
when you have depression or if your
typical or normal patient or subject and
therefore he has been been able to find
a section of the brain where you can
actually see a difference that he
hypothesizes has to do with attention
and one with cognition and one with mood
and what he's trying to do by
collaborating with people all over the
world and getting data whether someone
has autism or children who have ADHD is
to really start building curves so that
when you take your child to the
pediatrician and they take a height and
weight it's meaningless unless you can
put it on a curve so if your child has
always been very skinny and has always
been on the 25th percentile that gives
you some reassurance that the child is
moving along if your child becomes very
fat all of a sudden is now in the 75th
percentile the physician is worried as
to how that is different if we could
produce curves of what the trajectory
would look like for a child with autism
or a child with ADHD or depression when
a patient would come into the office who
seems very inattentive seems impulsive
by history seems hyperactive and you're
not sure that if you were able to be
able to do a resting state of the with a
functional MRI and the child doesn't
come on that curve of ADHD you might say
well there's another reason maybe it's
the parents are fighting maybe it's a
boring teacher maybe there's endless
reasons why someone could be inattentive
impulsive but if they have that history
and they had that biological marker
that's more evidence and gives more
confidence to the ability to make a
diagnosis and the earlier we are able to
make these diagnoses we certainly know
considering
the plasticity of the brain we are quite
convinced that will get better
treatments and be able to let kids have
much better lives we have 15 million
children in the United States today that
have a psychiatric disorder the
overwhelming majority never get any help
and what usually happens to them is they
they drop out of school they get in
trouble with the law and they go to jail
there are 7,000 child psychiatrists
there are 3,000 individuals who identify
themselves as child psychologists so the
math doesn't work so unless we're able
to figure out a better way of diagnosis
with more confidence and are able to
teach pediatricians how to diagnose and
evaluate and possibly treat or nurse
practitioners or
social workers to do this in a more
systematic way we will continue to lose
many many kids to the bed outcomes that
happen when you have these disorders